bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ça vous regarde en version d confiné
c'est parti voici le sommaire
l'automobile at elle encore un avenir en
france le président vient d'annoncer un
plan massif de soutien à la filière
frappé de plein fouet par la crise mais
dans le même temps renault s'apprête à
licencier massivement en fermant
plusieurs de ses sites comment
convaincre que l'état a les moyens de
garder son industrie la souveraineté
industrielle est elle autre chose qu'un
mot dans l'air du temps c'est notre
grand débat dans un instant salaire brut
1400 euros quelle profession commence à
ce niveau de rémunération avec un bac +
3 réponses
les infirmières au lendemain du coup
d'envoi du ségur de la santé nous
recevrons le porte parole du syndicat
national des personnels infirmiers pour
un dialogue sans concession avec le
législateur enfin le jour d'après nouvel
épisode de notre collection d'entretien
ce soir la dette les montagnes de dettes
qui s'abattent sur l'état qui va payer
la facture du coville 19 l'analyse du
prix nobel d'économie ce soir jean
tirole à l'attend cette émission voilà
donc pour le programme hashtag c'est
vers cela n'a pas changé on y va
[Musique]
et
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisir
lcp l'automobile symbolise à elle seule
notre tissu industriel voilà sans doute
pourquoi
emmanuel macron tenait à présenter lui
même le plan de soutien à la filière
il s'agit d'un plan de défense de notre
emploi industriel qui va être confronté
à l'une des plus graves crises de son
histoire
il s'agit d'un plan de souveraineté
industrielle automobile qui a vocation à
relocaliser de la valeur ajoutée et à
nous battre pour que la valeur ajoutée
les secteurs d'avenir se fasse en france
et il s'agit donc bien d'un plan
d'avenir de l'automobile du 21e siècle
voilà 8 milliards pour l'automobile des
mesures d aides à l'achat de véhicules
l'augmentation du bonus écologique prime
à la casse renforcer soutien aux
constructeurs aux sous traitants et
investissements dans l'électrique
on en parle ce soit avec vous bruno myle
yens bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député modem des yvelines
circonscription dans laquelle se situe
l'usiné de renault de flins
vous nous direz si vous êtes inquiet ce
soir ou rassurer on sait que la presse
place ce site dans les 6 4 sites menacés
on en parlera bonsoir benjamin cucq et
merci d'être là vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste du secteur automobile je
cite le livre noir de renault aux
éditions first
c'était c'était en 2013 juninho sur
citroën ford mais c'est renault qui fait
la une de l'actualité
je vous donne la parole messieurs dans
un instant celui qui va nous planter le
décor de ce plan de sauvetage du secteur
de l'automobile s'est blaco stéphane
blakowski derrière son écran ce soir si
j'ai bien compris on y va
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce
soir gamme l'automobile j'ai bien
compris si j'ai bien compris et myriam
vous m'arrêtez cinéma contre il est si
j'ai bien compris c'est épidémique et du
colis c'est vraiment une chance
inespérée pour l'industrie automobile
française
vous devez me trouvais très très
optimiste mais ça c'est parce que j'ai
eu en à une citation de bernanos dans le
journal qui disait le optimiste est un
imbécile heureux tandis que le
pessimisme est un imbécile malheureux
employé depuis j'essaie de voir le bon
côté des choses
pourtant je sais bien l'industrie
automobile a est vraiment au fond du
trou
- 80 % des ventes sur ces deux derniers
mois mais justement c'est quand on est
au fond du trou qu'on peut mettre la
fameuse impulsion des deux pieds pour
remonter à la surface
bon c'est le prix du public c'est
vraiment l'occasion aura élevé pour les
constructeurs céleri les deux grandes
mutations qu'on attend de leur part
c'est à dire premièrement fabriquer des
voitures moins polluantes et donc
électrique et une deuxième en fin de
lycée voitures en france pour relancer
l'emploi va chez vous mais bon même en
étant très optimiste
on sent que ont pas vraiment de loin
même de très loin pour ce qui est de la
relocalisation par exemple les bains
s'était pas franchement l'air du temps
récemment la le nouveau modèle renault
s'appelle quai où les transcrits en
slovénie en turquie le nouveau modèle
peugeot lui c'est la 208 il est fabriqué
au maroc
pour ce qui est de développer des
véhicules électriques c'est un peu
pareil c'est à dire que on a encore un
petit peu de temps avant que ça arrive
je vous montre un graphique à ses locaux
à mon avis voyez c'est la part de
véhicules électriques dans le nombre de
voitures vendues en france
alors oubliez vide dans sa lutte au
regard des liens en bas il est là et à
cesser les les titres dont il ya une
croissance constante mais ça reste
encore très faible
donc on en parle de ses voitures
électriques mais on n'en vend pas tant
que ça et donc même si avec la prime de
7000 euros ça peut même y rentrent à jeu
ça va prendre du temps
je sais pas si le président mal qu'on a
lu ce terme à nos cinq hommes - les
vacances mais en tout cas il est
optimiste et il a fixé des objectifs on
écoute faire de la france la première
nations productrices de véhicules
propres en europe
en portant à plus d'un million par an
sous cinq ans la production de véhicules
électriques hybrides rechargeables ou
hybrides et de consolider en parallèle
notre empreinte industriels
voilà un objectif optimiste mais bon
cela dit avant de l'atteindre il pas
déjà commencé parfois voire par des
stocker ces cinq cent mille voitures on
n'a pas réussi à vendre ces derniers
temps donc 96 % que ses voitures sont
des voitures à essence ou des voitures
diesel donc on sent bien que le nouveau
monde est en gestation et ou simplement
on va devoir attendre un petit peu je
pense pour inès taiclet attendre encore
un peu plus longtemps pour qu'il fasse
ses premiers pas mais restent optimistes
mais absolument toujours un optimisme
avec quoi clairvoyance pour relativement
prudent je voudrais qu'on fasse un point
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses déjà
dans le papier de stéphane sur cette
crise quatre cent mille véhicules qui
attend de voir 500 me d'ici la fin du
mois dans les parkings qui va falloir
absolument déstocker mais cette crise
elles datent pas du coc vide la crypte
d'automobiles français donc pas dû qu'au
vide mais l'été elle était sous un tapis
entre guillemets parce qu'on on avait un
début d'année qui partait en fanfare et
sur la voiture de la voiture électrique
qui était la dernière à bénéficier d'un
mât d'un bonus en 2020 a commencé avec
5% de part de marché et pas donc c'était
l'explosion 2020 devait être la voiture
électrique déjà dès janvier 7 annoncée
comme telle
mail annonce du million de voitures
produites aux raisons de 2005 2025
c'est intéressant actif de l'otan parce
que si si vous prenez la somme des lits
présidera public 10 voitures hybrides
rechargeables hybrides et électriques
si vous faites la somme de toutes ces
voitures qui sont fabriquées en déjà
actuellement doit déjà est à plus de 100
milles ce que toyota fabrique des yaris
200 milliards ici bride à peu près par
en france mais vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi dans ces cas là il y
avait déjà une crise qui existait au co
bible parce qu'on sent bien que voilà
personne n'a pu vouloir acheter de
voiture ce n'était pas possible
les les ventes ont chuté de 90% pendant
ces deux derniers mois mais avant le
marché même si dans les tous derniers
mois il était un tout petit peu plus en
sursaut pourquoi la voiture française
marche moins bien pourquoi la voiture
française marche moins bien parce que
pendant des années nous a expliqué que
nos emplettes étaient nos emplois comme
on dit et que toutes les voitures
françaises étaient délocalisées par une
gestion de gribouille de la part de la
part de l'état actionnaire qui a été qui
s'est comporté comme un fonds de pension
-7 8% de parts de marché déjà sur
janvier-février donc ça c'est avant la
crise du coi vide
oui mais c'est parce que le squelette
avait remis les clés dans les mains du
nom d'un malfrat qu'on aime qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle carlos ghosn
s'est encore mais je vous parle pas
seulement de renault il n'y a pas qu'au
renault qui va mal en france
oui et les non veux pas qu'on paie à sa
bien rebondis bien psa bien rebondir au
bout de la quatrième voiture la plus
vendue je crois que c'est la 3008
c'est une voiture dont le prix moyen est
à 35000 euros quand une voiture moyenne
en france
ce vent 27 c'est c'est ça va bien et
depuis on est à -4 8%
moi j'ai un rapport à l'année dernière
on va attendre de voir quand même ce que
donnent les résultats
mais juin sur les prises de commandes de
véhicules dans les concessions parce que
moi j'ai fait un peu le tour pas je n'ai
pas été chez les français je le dis mais
les choses ya que j'ai pas le temps
d'aller voir les français encore mais
chez les entrées chez les étrangers
notamment chez les allemands le
redémarrage a été quasi identique à
l'arrêt donc à dire en allemagne à vous
dire qu'on risque d'avoir des
concessionnaires allemands en france
donc on est en train de nous dire que si
ça se trouve les français leur priorité
c'est pas d'acheter une voiture je suis
pas persuadé que ce qu'ils avaient
l'intention d'acheter une voiture avant
la crise et renoncer à acheter ben non
donc c'est juste effectivement retardé
dans le temps mais je pense
qu'effectivement les ventes vont
souffrir
on est assez craignez pas qu'on est très
pessimiste sur le sol de peur des
ménages des français qui préfèreraient
épargner qu'ils ont raison de la crise
économique qui pourrait les toucher
le renouvellement d'une voiture c'est
tout et 40 mois à peu près beau dans
l'achat d'une voiture neuve entre 36 et
40 mois donc
et il se trouve que juste avant le juste
avant le confinement du 15 mars
on arrivait dans la dans la fameuse
période des deux journées portes
ouvertes chez tous les constructeurs qui
est une semaine de promotion où les
constructeurs il était à fond il s'est
laissé les seuls de l'automobile c'est
vous offre
l'autoradio la climatisation tout ça
parce que voiture l'ont aujourd'hui mais
c'est ont fait des grosses donc il avait
stocké des voitures qu'ils avaient prévu
de vendre donc c'est juste un décalage
dans le temps si on peut dire ça alors
si on regarde les mesures à présent on
va rester les principales
vous avez d'abord on en parlait le bonus
écologique la fête très clairement un
petit coup de pouce même un gros coup de
pouce un pour tous ceux qui il bride et
hybrides rechargeables hybride simple
l'hybride rechargeable est vraiment venu
de zeebrugge n'ont pas dit ce qui bride
simple 7000 euros pour l'achat d'un
véhicule électrique en particulier cent
mille pour une entreprise de 1000 euros
pour un achat de véhicules hybrides
franchement est-ce que ça va booster
l'électrique on a vu d'où partait quand
on sait que la zoé de renault elle est
quand même à plus de 20000 euros
walt 3025 1610
les ménages modestes c'est pas pour
demain c'est sûr ne sais pas c'est pas
j'ai vu que quand même que le plafond de
base de ses plus l'équivalent du smic
pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une prime à la
conversion c'est audrey le gouvernement
a réaugmenté le le barème pour
bénéficier d'une prime à la conversion
quart des français c'est d'abord sur les
mesures écologiques n'est pas forcément
sur l'électrique c'est important aussi
parce que ça met des voitures avec ces
primo il ya des primes locales qui
viennent
par exemple si vous habitez marseille où
les bouches du rhône vous avez droit
aussi quelques milliers d'euros prime
supplémentaire et d'app line primes qui
sont cumulables en france d'une région à
l'autre sur le sur l'électrique c'est
très insécurisant cela va marcher très
incitatif
parce que 1 renault prépare la quid
électrique la kz2 qui émeut qu'un petit
et suivait une petite mini citadine
électrique 100 % électrique et le groupe
volkswagen a déjà lancé en bail sa veuve
est un peu la grosse annonce du début du
printemps
mais trois véhicules sur la base de deux
seat skoda et volkswagen de 2 min et les
que deux petites voitures électriques
aux alentours de 12 13 mille 14000 euros
donc c'est à dire que pour 12000 euros
vous aviez une voiture qui ne vous
coûtent rien à usage du skoda citigo une
seat mii électrique chilienne sur
l'électrique pour répondre quand même à
stéphane blakowski quand on voit d'où on
part sur la vendée loire salah reproche
qu'on peut faire aux cons ça dit on est
loin de la transition quand même
reproche qu'on fait en constructeur
français si je peux me permettre c'est
qu'effectivement ils n'ont pas été sur
cette technologie aussi vite que nos
amis japonais notamment toyota sur les
mêmes sur les brides sur les doigts ça
fait dix ans les lectrices
ça fait dix ans que renault vend des
oeufs après je ne sais moi j'arrive pas
à comprendre jusqu'où tg j'ai fait j'ai
fait l'expérience d'un moment ça dans ma
circonscription
quelqu'un qui a un vieux véhicule diesel
qui polluent et c'est quand on regarde
le coût à l'année du véhicule commence à
être assez important et le gars me dis
moi j'ai pas les moyens d'acheter une
zone ça coûte trop cher à ce que vous
avez dit et moi tu l'achètes pourquoi tu
as loupé à bosser plus d'auteurs
pourquoi tu la loue pas pourquoi tu fais
pas une loi ou une location à longue
durée à la propriété d'un véhicule que
oui mais il faut comprendre quand même
que c'est quand même comprendre qu' on a
fait le cas
ayant fait le calcul tous les deux et au
bout du compte la réalité pas gagnant de
beaucoup avec la zone c'est peut-être
gagnant de 20 ou 30 euros par mois mais
c'est quand même 20 ou 30 euros par mois
et l'argument final pour moi c'était
c'est bien donc il faut il faut des suv
aussi c'est l'argument final il est
chasseur et me dit oui mais comment je
mets le chevreuil dans le coffre de la
zoé sur le
sur l'argument du l'argument de la
location au contraire moi pour une
voiture pour une voiture électrique si
je devais en acheter une demain je vais
racheter j'irais plutôt l'apprendra et
l'oat pourrais moi aussi c'est que vous
avez la garantie qu'elle est reprise
dans trois ans par le constructeur et
vous n'êtes pas embarrassé à la vendre
parce qu'on sait à peu près ce que vaut
une twingo thermique
vive la location de voiture je vais
lever mais la loi a beaucoup augmenté
c'était fade nous entends je le sais
mais là l eau à l eau à l aile d ce sont
des systèmes de vente qui ont
excessivement augmenté ces dernières
années en france et en mieux grâce à la
faiblesse des taux d'intérêt il avoue
aussi sourire ou pas stéphane blakowski
cet échange est vraiment simple enjeu
j'entendais l'espoir qu'on avait que
tout le monde s'équiper notamment les
gens les plus modestes avec des
politiques mais si le savant de là
imaginer qu'ils connaissaient rien hier
et j'ai vu ce midi sur le sujet et je
vois le classement des ventes en france
donc la zoé alors en tête est la
deuxième voiture dans le classement
c'était une tesla
donc on voitures américaines de 2,2 kg
cher quand même c'est simplement qu'il
n'est pas de marcher à côté d'une
voiture
bonjour donc c'est soit une zoé soit une
bagnole on dit aujourd'hui on sent les
moyens d'aller 2008 le marché
excusez moi mais ça a longtemps a
longtemps eu juste deux petites voitures
qui étaient là c'est zéro et la peugeot
ion qu'il avait beaucoup de mal à vendre
et là il a fait une grosse ans le groupe
a fait une grosse grosse offensive avec
la la ds3 chez des grosses vagues
il a hélas
la lah 2008 la 208
il ya des voitures hybrides chez citroën
aussi est par contre c'est vrai qu'il ya
un problème c'est que est ce que là les
nouvelles mesures
est ce qu'elles vont être plafonnés
comme étaient les précédentes mesures
c'est à dire que le plafond pour
bénéficier d'une prime à l'achat d'une
voiture électrique cette voiture
électrique ne devait pas excéder 45
mille euros précédemment est-ce que là
on a fait sauter le plafond parce qu'il
faudrait pas voir non pas regarder dans
le détail les gens inquiets chuterait de
tesla bah oui c'est l'enfer blanc qui ya
il ya de l'investissement très clair et
l'incitation sur une transition verte
donc l'électrique avec d'ailleurs un
grand plan pour installer des bornes sur
tout le territoire mais ça c'est encore
hélas batteries renault va passer dans
l'airbus de la batterie ça c'est du long
terme
à court terme les ménages modestes et
c'est là qu'on est moins écolo les
primes à la casse et un cessez le nom
pour nom commun pour dire la prima
conversion là on est sûr de la voiture
qui pollue sur du moteur thermique
moi je jouais pourra rejouer qu'on
arrête un tout petit peu lâché
effectivement que ça pollue plus qu'une
voiture électrique mais peut-être pas si
vous regardez le bilan carbone complet
la voiture non je suis pas d'accord avec
une voiture électrique un bilan carbone
option son cycle de vie totale du puits
à la destruction de sa source matières
premières jusqu'à destruction trois fois
moindre qu'une voiture thermique à ma
puissance équivalente toutefois il ya
quelque chose qui est vrai c'est que la
france dans tous les pays industrialisés
en ont dans l'union européenne a le
meilleur bilan carbone par habitant pour
une voiture c'est à dire qu'on est à 111
g
les français si je passe que vous avez
vous comme voiture comme une voiture et
votre voiture en moyenne elle va émettre
111 g
les allemands c'est 140 grammes les
anglais c'est 150 donc on est on est pas
si mauvais 3000 euros pour l'achat d'un
véhicule neuf ou d'occasion
5000 pour l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique qui se rajouterait au bonus
écologique là je parle de changer de
véhicule et entre trois et cinq mille
pour l'achat d'un véhicule hybride
il faut faire aussi des gestes quand
c'est la crise économique pour les
ménages plus modestes qui tu as il faut
déstocker tous et tous et tous ces
véhicules qui sont sur les parkings ce
sont des moteurs à essence qui sont sur
les peurs oui mais le moins émetteur
faiblement émetteurs ça va pas être déçu
mon moteur c'est pas des mains 6 oui on
a une image là je vous rejoins on a une
image de la voiture thermique
aujourd'hui qui est une voiture
excessivement poland comme celle qu'on a
connue chez nos parents nos
grands-parents les moteurs ont
énormément progressé
enfin même en diesel pourtant je ne
devrais pas le dire je me fais engueuler
mais l'adblue l'adblue en diesel ça a
été une vraie révolution pour les
moteurs diesel en termes de pollution
alors c'est pas suffisant on peut pas
rester sur les moteurs thermiques il
faut qu'on avance vers les nouvelles
technologies des nouvelles technologies
c'est des voitures propres ces des
voitures propres et demain des voitures
connectées hockey ce plan présenté par
le président un conte va dans ce sens là
et on va ainsi localiser l'ensemble de
la construction automobile à valeur
ajoutée c'est-à-dire en gros tous les
véhicules jusque d'autre avenir que les
véhicules d'avenir je pense que
effectivement comme on l'avait fait
croyez ça vous pensez que c'est à dire
que j'en sache à quoi on va fermer des
usines à l'étranger on va faire revenir
ces problèmes étaient enfin la monette
mans le problème n'est pas d'y croire ou
pas c'est qu'on a un besoin impératif de
le faire sinon c'est fini l'industrie
automobile en france peut mettre une
croix dessus parce que c'est des autres
qui fabriqueront voilà donc il ya un
moment on a pris quand même du retard
sur des concurrents qui sont plutôt vers
le vers l'asie vers le sud est asiatique
qui ont alors c'est le paradoxe chrono 1
renault est très en avance sur le moteur
électrique notamment et sur les sur
l'importation du moteur dans la voiture
mais en terme de modèle il y en a pas eu
beaucoup de développer non c'est ça mais
c'était le problème c'était
pour revenir toujours aux racines du mal
le sait qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui a géré
renault de manière qu'elle est et ça a
été pour nous pourquoi je me sens assez
bas de votre ami c'est sûr non non non
pas censé être un peu jour psa va bien
psa va très bien non je parle au web
mais je parlais sur la tactique
moi j'entends cette envie qu'on a tous
de relocaliser de rengainer notre
souveraineté
mais je me méfie toujours des idées
soudaine qui viennent de l ont souvent
des racines assez peu profondes
moi quand je gratte un peu je vois juste
que la dernière le dernier mais les clio
qui est le modèle de renault qui se
vendent plus a été délocalisée ailleurs
toutes les lignes to be
le dernier modèle de 108 qu'on voit
partout dans l'être dans les pubs il est
fabriqué au maroc dont le monde demande
un oui oui non mais ce qui se passe
c'est que peugeot fabriquer et psa
peugeot uniquement mais psa fabrique
encore un million de voitures en france
peugeot fabrique un pardon renault
fabrique encore 700 mille véhicules
ce qu'ils intègrent aussi tous ces
utilitaires à l' usine de maubeuge et
qui n'est pas en danger elle par contre
48,6 non les 5 milliards
c'est l'aide de l'état ne cessons ce
sont des véhicules qui sont rentables
c'est on fabrique encore un peu de
voitures en france
effectivement on a beaucoup délocalisé
mais quand on a vu le comportement
le comportement assez suicidaire de la
cgt il ya quinze jours à sandouville de
pour une action pour une action en
justice pour une vraiment une
une argutie juridique de dire ah non non
il faut pas on peut pas reprendre le
boulot alors que les gars de lasser de
fo de la cfdt la cftc la cgt et cgc
étaient tous d'accord
la cgt a fait bloquer la reprise gère
une histoire de procédures vos histoires
de procès mais quel exemple ils sont pas
là pour se défendre sur ce plateau
comment ça se fait comment ça se passe
aux états unis on avait envie de se
poser la question ce soir dans ça vous
regarde bonsoir françois durpaire ravi
de vous retrouver françois alors vous
êtes évidemment historien spécialiste
des têtes des états unis et chroniqueur
dans cette émission la relance
industrielle à la donald trump est ce
qu'elle est écolo ou pas alors vous avez
parlé effectivement en voiture propre
relance écolo industrie demain ça va pas
vous étonner mais donald trump il est
plus attaché à l'industrie d'hier à
l'énergie qui polluent parce que
l'énergie qui polluent c'est le pétrole
et le pétrole est au plus bas en ce
moment l'une de ses premières mesures
vous en souvenez c'était de détricoter
toutes les mesures moins de co2 qui
avait mis en place barack obama
notamment dans l'industrie automobile et
s'était opposé à la californie qui vous
savez et l'état leader aux états unis
sur les voitures propres alors est-ce
que le coronavirus lui a fait changer
d'avis pas du tout parce que maintenant
il a si vous voulez comme à tous les
américains qui a 78 % disent nous ce qui
nous intéresse c'est d'acheter américain
c'est son fameux made in america
pourquoi vais parce que le coronavirus à
murray un certain nombre de pénurie les
masques les ventilateurs les
thermomètres pour la première économie
du monde qui n'est plus la première
industrie du monde depuis 2010 c'est la
chine alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant cette période et bien notamment
ce qui s'est passé c'est ce décret que
donald trump a signé de supprimer toutes
les réglementations environnementales
qui pourraient entraver la reprise
économique
donc très clairement l'écologie est
sacrifiée sous le thème de la guerre
froide contre la chine un dernier mot
pour
vous dire quand même que demain et bien
c'est le lancement de la fusée space x
donc là on n'est pas dans le monde
d'après on est bien dans le monde des
années 60 avec dans le rôle de la russie
la chine la chine qui a envoyé vous vous
rappelez il ya quinze jours une fusée
avec son plan des chinois sans la lune
avant 2024
donc là donald trump il est dans dans ce
monde d'hier dans ce monde du xxème
siècle où henri bus disait vous vous
rappelez le xxème siècle c'est le siècle
américain c'est la nostalgie de donald
trump et là les voitures propres
est ce une très très loin merci merci
beaucoup françois pour ce tour d'horizon
c'est la fin de ce débat
je voulais qu'on dise un mot quand même
pour terminer très rapidement sur sur
renault rno petits faire faillite ou pas
bah non moi je crois pas mais par contre
ce qui m'interroge c'est la capite la
valeur boursière actuelle de renault
c'est 5 milliards d'euros c'est à dire à
peu près le prêt auquel l'état va
consentir à ce qu'ils auraient pas été
plus simple de faire que comme barack
obama fait en son temps pour general
motors
c'est à dire de racheter toutes les
actions pour 5 milliards nationalisées
ont nationalisé provisoirement et
reprivatiser ensuite parce que l'état
l'état est souvent pas très bon
gestionnaire dans les uns dans les
industries
donc voilà je le presse et ça nous
permet d'obtenir plus de renault
finalement que d'être aux commandes
bon et vous ne dites ce soir flins et
s'ouvrir n'aura pas ni ni aujourd'hui ni
demain
moi je peux parier pour demi le 30 mai
la cour terme la zoé produite à flins
flins continuerait
merci merci à tous les deux d'être
laissant éclater une bonne idée de
nationaliser malgré tout parce que sinon
si on profite du court très très bas de
l'action renault actuellement
donc c'est à voir l'ensemble du groupe
est assez bas prix si le gouvernement
est toujours de son plan et que le cours
l'action remonte d'ici un an ou deux on
fait une bonne opération et patronaux ce
serait le mot de la fin j'ai
l'impression voilà vous vous êtes tous
les deux d'accord un débat entre gens
d'accord merci merci beaucoup on va
parler à présent du salaire des
infirmiers et des infirmières on les
applaudit tous les soirs à 20h vous le
savez mais cette reconnaissance doit
maintenant se traduire en sonnant
et en trébuchant alors la revalorisation
sera significative
c'est ce qu'a promis edouard philippe
hier contrairement ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire combien surtout 200 300 400
euros de plus avant d'accueillir nos
invités rabhi cas et cédric delbarre ont
suivi maurice 50 ans 19 19 ans de métier
témoignage maurice 50 ans est marié et
père de trois enfants il est infirmier
depuis 19 ans et voilà ce qu'il gagne à
la fin du mois en travaillant la nuit et
les week-ends jean ferrier on peut avoir
un salaire de 2000 278 euros 35 l ap-hp
ben écoutez sais c'est pas suffisant
c'est tout ce qu'on vous dit rien c'est
beaucoup ce qu'on voudrait c'est pas
suffisant pas suffisant lorsqu'on se
compare à d'autres métiers lorsqu'on
voit l'importance qu'on peut avoir
notamment dans la période douala connu
avec le conte vide 19 on voit que mine
de rien
les efforts que l'on fait le travail
qu'on fournit le service qui a rendu ça
ne faut pas quoi je me dis que c'est
insuffisant convient de différer pour
que ce soit satisfaisant 400 euros de
plus ces serments c'est pas volé c'est
pas voulu s'avancer pas volé 400 euros
de plus
parce que ça ne permettrait d'être plus
tranquille dans la gestion financière
plus tranquille dans tout l'est ce qui
est extra vous savez cinéma loisirs et
tournai autres parce que là c'est serré
dans la gestion quotidienne
c'est très serré des réseaux sont
quotidiennes en a pas on n'a pas idée
mais même en habitant hlm on est en
loyer de 800 euros
je peux pas dire que je suis malheureux
cependant c'est très difficile parce
qu'on a des charges ses trois enfants
qui vont encore à l'école ils sont
scolarisés pour 2 200 scolarisons encore
et voilà ça c'est un coup tout ça la vie
est chère en banlieue parisienne
si nous restons au 20 du mois ou 24 du
vin veuve du mois c'est bon on est à
moins de 100 -300 -400 voilà vous
souhaitez les découverts il ya après ça
repart quand apple arrive plongeurs
comme ça le gouvernement dit avoir
entendu le message
hier le premier ministre a annoncé une
revalorisation significative du salaire
des soignants dans les mois à venir et
on en parle avec vous du salaire des
soignants thierry amouroux bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes le porte parole du
syndicat national des personnels
infirmiers figure de proue de la
contestation à l'hôpital public face à
vous stéphanie rist bonsoir soit merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député la
république en marge du loiret députés
médecins et vous étiez en première ligne
co rapporteur de la précédente réforme
de l'hôpital l'hôpital a tenu pendant
cette crise du coc vide on a applaudi
les soignants tous les soignants tous
les soirs à 20h vous aurez bientôt
d'ailleurs une médaille mais franchement
qu'est ce que vous vous dites on est sur
le point de vous augmentez alors on sait
pas encore de combien mais il a fallu
locaux vides
c'est ça l'état d'esprit sans le covin
pas d'augmentation oui c'est ça qui est
terrible parce qu on est quand même au
troisième plan
un an et ma santé 2022 il ya eu le grand
plan hôpital de novembre dernier
annoncée par le premier ministre et puis
on va sur le terrain il n'y a pas un
centime qui est arrivé ni pour le
personnel ni pour les hôpitaux alors le
premier ministre a dit que ce serait
significatif
il ya une prime il faut l'expliquer ça
peut-être allé un peu tardé à venir mais
vous avez eu cette cette prime entre 500
et 1500 euros pourrait évidemment tout
ce que vous avez fait pendant pendant
cette crise sanitaire qui n'est pas
terminée et puis il va y avoir ces
augmentations ça progresse ça y est ça
discute là alors pour ce qui est de la
prime est là étaient 1500 euros pour les
soignants du public dans 40 départements
elle a été de 500 euros pour les
soignants du public dans 60 départements
donc les plus nombreux et puis vous avez
les héros à zéro euro
ceux qui sont du secteur privé lucratif
du secteur privé non lucratif ceux qui
sont du secteur libéral
les intérimaires et les vacataires qui
sont venus dans les hôpitaux publics
pour renforcer les auriez préféré que ce
soit l'ensemble des soignants fumée
comme privé qui soit bénéficiaire d'un
contre sur la volonté politique vous
avez entendu le mea culpa quand même du
président de la république c'est pas
rien à mulhouse
il a reconnu que le plan les plans
hôpitaux on va y venir n'était pas allé
assez loin et assez fort sur la question
des salaires
vous la sentez la volonté politique ou
pas si vous voulez l'annnonce du plan
hôpital de novembre dernier c'était on
donne des moyens à l'hôpital va y avoir
des milliards etc
et puis un mois après ben
il y avait le vote du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
l'objectif de dépenses d'assurance
maladie donc le budget des hôpitaux qui
est augmenté de 2,1 à 2,3 alors que les
besoins de l'hôpital sont de 4 % par an
avec le coût des médicaments innovants
de la recherche c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
encore des plans d'économies même si
elle était moins importante que qu'avant
mais sur l'état d'esprit du collectif
que vous représentez oui vous sentez que
les lignes bougent vous être confiant
parce que quand même les discours ont
bougé et non ils ont changé alors nous
sommes confiants par rapport à la
mobilisation populaire c'est à dire que
la population est avec nous parce
qu'elle a réalisés dans quel état était
l'hôpital
et d'ailleurs c'est les pays du sud
que ce soit la france l'italie l'espagne
en rue des plans d'économies depuis une
dizaine d'années est sûre les hôpitaux
et on a eu quatre fois plus de morts que
l'allemagne qui n'a pas eu de plan
d'économies sur les hôpitaux donc pour
un euro d'économiser sur sur dix ans eh
bien on en dépense 10 aujourd'hui
alors on va venir sur ce que vous
demandez ce que vous réclamez parce que
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas très bien
classé
quand on regarde je parle des infirmiers
et des infirmières on est 22e sur sur 33
pour la france une carrière elle
commence à 1500 euros nets en début de
carrière c'est très peu par rapport à la
moyenne européenne
elle s'achève à 2400 euros nets
qu'est ce qui explique un tel retard
stephanie rice alors comme vous l'avez
dire je suis pas d'accord sur tout ce
que j'avais dit certes on sort de
plusieurs quinquennat de d'économies
très importante sur l'hôpital depuis que
nous sommes arrivés au pouvoir quand
même même si je reconnais que c'est pas
suffisant qu'il faut aller plus vite
nous avons quand même été le premier
gouvernement depuis ces dix dernières
années a augmenté les tarifs
hospitaliers
donc arrêtez la baisse des tarifs
hospitaliers on est à + 5 milliards
entre 2018 et 2020 sur les dépenses pour
la santé
restant sur les salaires parce que là
c'est sur les salaires
ce qui intéresse ça nous avons échappé
pendant le tallec nadal monsieur
hollande une gel un gel des salaires
pendant cinq ans qui a fait perdre 4 %
de 2,4 pour cent de pouvoir d'achat des
personnels soignants
donc il ya eu on est arrivé à ce moment
là et il faut relancer la machine et ré
élevé laisse beaucoup personnellement
comme député vous êtes favorable à une
augmentation d'avoir et moi je pense et
les rejets en politique sur ceux ci les
rémunérations des personnels soignants
des infirmiers des infirmes et ouais je
le disais ya trois ans en m'engageant en
politique c'est ce que plusieurs choses
améliorer l'organisation pour que chacun
puisse avoir accès aux soins et
revaloriser les métiers notamment en
termes de formation
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur la loi santé
sur la partie formation sur les
l'évolution des formations des
infirmières ou des aides soignantes pour
qu'ils aient une évolutivité du métier
je crois qu'un il faut revaloriser les
salaires mais il faut aussi avoir une
une carrière qui puissent évoluer dans
tout ce que vous reconnaissez peut-être
des erreurs ou en tout cas dans la
communication ou peut-être de ne pas
avoir pris la mesure pas forcément vous
en tant qu' en tant que législateur vous
connaissez bien ses dossiers mais là je
parle de l'exécutif du prêt le ministre
du président de la république la mesure
des attentes
il a fallu quand même des mois de grèves
qui finalement sans lequel il n'aurait
peut-être pas abouti c'est quand même
pas normal non alors les mois de grève
ont quand même été entendu en novembre
avec l' annonce du plan il ya eu des
milliards de mis en jeu sur la table
avec une reprise de la dette des
hôpitaux de 10 milliards il faut la
mettre en place c'était en novembre mais
ça c'est pas les salaires fait pour
l'investissement dans l'hôpital il ya eu
au total il est celle des prix des
personnels a aussi des salaires mais qui
sont quand même parce que vous avez dit
y'a aucun argent qui arrivent et s'il ya
quand même eu la prime pour les gens qui
travaillent aux urgences ou dans les
services à risque qui a été mise depuis
le mois de juillet à l'angleterre le
prime de 800 euros par an qui a été
donné dans quatre des percements sur les
jeux si ça parce que je veux juste dire
que il ya eu
il ya eu une écoute et la sensation est
le premier ministre l'a dit le cap était
bon et je pense aussi que le cap est bon
de baisser les tarifs de réorganiser la
ville les soins entre la ville et
l'hôpital mais là les augmentations
significatives la question c'est combien
qu'est ce que vous réclamez précisément
thierry hamon alors nous ce que l'on
réclame c'est 300 euros net par mois
alors c'est pas au doigt mouillé que
l'on a calculé ça c'est l' ocde qui
n'ont aucun ouvrier exactement comme
dans le reportage qu'on entendait voilà
cet infirmier qui dit 400 euros et on
rattrape la moyenne européenne
voilà le différentiel entre le salaire
moyen infirmiers en france il s'avère
moins bien faire les européens c'est 300
euros donc on demande une revalorisation
de 2 300 320 euros de moins que notre
témoin à les y voilà
mais ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
elle arrive rapidement parce que si on
nous dit c'est 300 euros pour dans 20
ans avec des paliers de 15 euros par an
sur 20 ans je pense que ça même vite
tourné au vinaigre on n'y avait que ce
ne sera pas possible de faire 300 d'un
coup c'est ce que vous attendez est ce
que est ce que je me trompe en disant ça
stephanie rice
est ce que c'est possible que le
gouvernement développe j'imagine là je
trouve que des terres la taille là je
pense pas je crois que vu la crise qu'on
vient de deux qu'on est en train de
traverser encore ça serait réducteur de
vouloir juste les 300 euros
je crois qu'on doit revoir la position
de ces métiers des toits niant
d'infirmières de jouer sur les 300 euros
c'est assez oui ou c'est non
vous êtes les les discussions commencent
mais vous personnellement si si on vous
dit voilà à partir de 300 euros a dit
aussi aller vers la moyenne européenne
paraît logique en restant dans les
dépenses européennes puisque on a les
mêmes dépenses de santé donc il va
falloir de la réorganisation à côté
parce qu'on dépense autant que
l'allemagne mais nos infirmières sont
moins bien payés en santé en dépensant
le pourcentage de pib est le même en
dépenses hospitalières que celui de
l'allemagne
au regard de la population descend tout
de suite au 12e rang la france
ça coûterait juste combien à l'état si
on débloquait ses 300 euros pour tous
les fonctionnaires hospitaliers type
infirmier aide soignante est ce qu on a
chiffré mais est surtout une fois qu'on
aura donné les 300 euros en plus par
mois ce qu'on fait après moi c'est
plutôt ça qui m'intéresse comment on va
réorganiser
j'entends bien mais ça c'est une autre
question ça c'est la réorganisation de
l'hôpital la question des époques où les
directeurs et évidemment sur ces 300
euros combien je n'ai pas le givre
calculer mais c'est évidemment beaucoup
d'argent
300 euros pour un grand nombre de
personnels mais c'est à mon sens c'est
un sujet important la revalorisation sur
lequel on s'est engagé il va y avoir des
choix à faire et je crois moi je
défendrai ce choix évidemment mais je
crois aussi et surtout que c'est le
moment de mettre à plat les tabous de
notre système de santé pour que enfin
alors ce soir délaissant les hauts de
lausanne qui a dû vivre dans la gestion
la logique de rentabilité à l'hôpital la
date déjà l'être qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
les grands tabous en fait même sans
prendre des grands tabous quand on
compare avec les pays européens on a le
même pourcentage de pib de dépenses on a
en nombre de lits à part avec
l'allemagne qui a beaucoup plus de lits
privés à part avec l'allemagne on est
dans les pays qui avons le plus de lits
et pourtant les soignants disons manque
de lits donc il ya un sujet organisation
sur le nombre de lits sur le territoire
il faut arrêter de vouloir à tout prix
ne pas avoir de l'évident l hôpital bon
je vous retrouver l'idée d'un lit vide à
l'hôpital quand quatre kovy 12 ou de
maladies qui pourraient affluer ces
c'est une possibilité de penser des
choses enfin comme ça simplement en cas
de coup vite parce qu'il faut voir que
hors contexte épidémique
si les gens restent sur des brancards
aux urgences c'est parce que y'a pas
glee de disponible dans l'hôpital pour
ceux qui doivent être hospitalisés et
leur corps que l'on ait eu c'est un
homme de 72 ans qui restait cinq jours
sur un brancard ou au chu de
saint-etienne en juillet
dernier et parce que lorsqu'on demande
aux services de faire 100 % dans
d'occupation eh bien vous avez pas dit
libre pour accueillir quelqu'un qui est
aux urgences ci a tellement d'attentes
aux urgences aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on a fermé 95 petits services
d'urgence sur ces dix dernières années
donc là où servier trois petits services
d'urgence ou vous attendiez deux heures
maintenant vous avez un énorme service
d'urgence
nous vous attend dès 12h pourrait qu'on
revienne à la question des rémunérations
qui est lié aussi au temps de travail
vous avez entendu le premier ministre
il est question de remettre les 35
heures sur sur la table vous vous êtes
aux 35 heures j'imagine à l'hôpital
public
non les hôpitaux sont en 38 heures et il
ya quinze rtt par an pour compenser ce
d'arriver à les prendre non pas du tout
ça s'accumule sur des comptes épargne
temps par exemple sur à l'ap-hp vous
avez plus d'un million de deux jours de
rtt qui sont accumulés c'est pareil pour
les heures supplémentaires elles sont
payées pas payé alors il ya de tout et
il ya de tout y est déjà les heures
gratuit c'est à dire que les audits ont
montré que chaque soignant c'est 45
minutes gratuites chaque jour entre
leurs deux fins et le moment où on
réellement elle va au vestiaire et ça
c'est ni récupérer ni payées et
lorsqu'on dit ben écoutez ça fait tant
d'heures à la fin du mois on vous dit
mais c'est vous qui est mal organisé ma
question stéphane restée est ce que en
mettant fin aux 35 heures à l'hôpital
c'est le gouvernement va jusque là ou en
tout cas en reposant le problème c'est
pas un moyen d'augmenter travailler plus
pour gagner plus au fond les internes et
sans passer par la case revalorisation
on parlait d' arrêter les tabous je
connais une infirmière qui travaille
dans une clinique privée pour arrondir
ses fins nous enfin pour augmenter ses
fins de mois
une aide soignante qui travaillent en
ville pour aller récupérer des personnes
âgées parce que de la même façon elle
doit gagner plus donc ce qu'on a
expliqué c'est de dire mettons ça sur la
table et voyons comment ça peut se
passer de façon pragmatique je crois que
c'est le terme qui avait utilisé le
premier ministre mais je crois que ça
fait partie des
des tableaux plutôt que d'aller
travailler ailleurs est alors on cherche
aussi des compétences mais ça n'en
energy sse la revalorisation et ça
n'empêche pas aussi de mettre plus de
personnel parce que je crois que ce qui
est en tout cas de mon vécu de chef de
service ou de chefs de pôles ces
dernières années ce qui est important
c'est que les conditions de travail
aussi soit soit bonne il ya bien sûr le
salaire mais les conditions de travail
est actuellement dans beaucoup de
services
on n'a pas et notamment les services qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées on n'a
pas assez de personnel vous parlez les
tabous à l'instant à l'hôpital on
évoquer ceux qui vont dans le privé ou
qui cumule avec le privé en plus du
public mais aussi le tabou de ceux qui
préfèrent exercer tout simplement
ailleurs bonsoir richard wehrli derrière
votre écran je suis ravi de vous
retrouvez vous dans votre chronique ce
soit vous allez nous vous parler de ces
personnes ces personnels soignants qui
n'hésite pas au fond à passer les
frontières pour aller travailler chez
nous voisins européens eh bien oui
effectivement myriam une frontière vous
le savez c'est toujours une forme de
miroir et dans le secteur de la santé
particulièrement regardé il y a le grand
duché du luxembourg ce petit pays de
cinq cent mille habitants où 40 % du
personnel médical vient de l'étranger
parmi ces 40 % la moitié viennent de
france les hôpitaux de metz ou de
thionville ils en savent quelque chose
d'ailleurs ils s'en sont relativement
plein au moment de la crise due qu'au
guide
je me suis trouvé aussi vous le rappelle
vous le rappeler à sarrebruck dans la
province de la sarre allemande également
frontalière de la france est bien là il
y a eu un gros problème lors de la
fermeture de la frontière le 16 mars par
angela merkel c'est parce qu'un certain
nombre de départements dans les hôpitaux
ne pouvait plus fonctionner alors
pourquoi les médecins et infirmières
français repartent à l'étranger en
allemagne mais aussi en suisse voire
même en belgique il y à la rémunération
alors un seul chiffre
on va prendre celui des hôpitaux de
genève ou de lausanne une infirmière
démarre à 5000 euros un médecin peut
escompter entre 7000 et 8000 euros
mais il n'ya pas que ça j'entendais à
l'instant parler des conditions de
travail
on entend souvent et ça a été dit lors
d'un sondage récent en allemagne
les personnels français expatriés parler
d'une plus grande responsabilisation
d'une meilleure organisation de travail
de moins de paperasse de moins de
bureaucratie
bref tout ça rend ces pays extrêmement
attractif pour une corporation qui ne se
sent pas valorisées en france alors on
pourrait se poser la question puisque
une grande négociation est lancée
est ce que madame nota qui est en charge
de ce dossier ne devrait pas invité à
paris des directeurs d'hôpitaux
allemands suisses ou luxembourgeois pour
témoigner et raconter ce qu'il faut
parce qu on l'oubli il y a eu beaucoup
de solidarité pendant cette crise du coc
vide les hôpitaux allemands à sarrebruck
notamment ont accueilli des patients
français il y à des échanges permanents
des deux côtés de la frontière
ce serait peut-être l'occasion de
comprendre ce qui fonctionne mieux à
l'étranger et pourquoi les soignants
français de temps en temps préfère
franchir la frontière que de rester en
france
merci beaucoup richard pour terminer ce
débat d'un mot c'est aussi une crise de
vocations que celui de soignants
d'infirmiers parce que c'est difficile
c'est mal payés et donc il ya moins il
ya moins de postes il ya beaucoup manqué
j'imagine d'infirmiers et d'infirmières
dans votre service et avoue travailler
alors il manque des gens oui parce qu'il
ya aussi une perte de sens c'est à dire
que nous on veut être infirmière à
l'hôpital prendre soin des patients et
on est confronté une administration qui
ne nous demandent plutôt des deux
techniciennes spécialisée dans une usine
à soins salir enchaîner des actes
techniques sans prendre la personne
l'accompagné lui expliquer le traitement
était ravissant infirmières manque à
l'assistance publique des hôpitaux de
paris pour terminer c'est tout l'enjeu
de ce ségur c'est l'attractivité un des
métiers qui étaient en première ligne
c'est d'une part cette reconnaissance
qu'on a tous auprès de ses personnels et
est vraiment d'essayer de construire
pour demain et pour pour la suite
meilleur et bien vous avez métier cette
semaine pour y parvenir puisque ce ségur
comme on l'appelle ce ségur de la santé
doit accoucher de propositions négociées
avec les syndicats et le gouvernement
d'ici le mois de juillet vous restez
avec nous
stephanie rice sava s'ouvre sans doute
vous intéressez vous intéresser cette
actu les groupes parlementaires qui
pousse un peu comme des champignons au
palais bourbon
après la création d'un neuvième groupe
la semaine dernière voici donc un
dixième comme va nous l'expliqué thomas
des prêts pour sa journée à l'assemblée
thomas où est il ce soir thomas 8 9 et
10 voilà myriam le record du nombre de
groupe à l'assemblée nationale est battu
je vous raconte tout ça jingle ou alors
c'était la surprise de ce mardi matin un
dixième groupe parlementaire après le
neuvième écologie démocratie et
solidarité la semaine dernière voici
agir ensemble un nouveau groupe qui se
veut être le troisième pilier de la
majorité entre la république en marche
et le modem
mais à quoi va servir ce nouveau groupe
avec clément perreault on a posé la
question à celui qui va le diriger
le député du haut rhin olivier becht
bonjour monsieur le président ce lydiane
groupe a pas fertile
il sert d'abord à être au rendez vous de
l'histoire nous vivons en ce moment la
pire crise économique et sociale
probablement de toute l'histoire moderne
et donc il faut impérativement pouvoir
aujourd'hui reconstruire un nouveau
modèle économique social et
environnemental
donc nous sommes là d'abord et avant
tout que pour faire bouger les lignes
être une force de propositions
constructives qui est en appui des
actions du président de la république et
du gouvernement
deux groupes en moins d'une semaine ça
fait un peu beaucoup non si vous voulez
les groupes s'organisent à l'intérieur
de l'assemblée nationale c'est un signe
de vitalité de notre démocratie tu es ce
un signe du pluralisme
il ya néanmoins ceux qui sont clairement
avec la majorité
c'était le cas de l'as raismes c'était
le cas également du modem il est
aujourd'hui un troisième groupe
constructif aux côtés de cette majorité
c'est agir ensemble et puis il ya
d'autres groupes qui sont plutôt dans
l'opposition et qui font valoir une
autre voie alors dans ce groupe on
retrouve 17 députés neuf du groupe udi
agir et indépendant un du groupe liberté
et territoires et 7 de la république en
marche qui perd encore des membres alors
bien sûr gilles legendre s'en serait
bien passé même s'il relativise nous
n'avons pas souhaité la création de ce
groupe
nous pouvons même nous
interrogé sur l'opportunité d'une
création de ce groupe au moment que nous
vivons
l'épiné dorsale de la majorité
numériquement et politiquement reste
très clairement la république en marge
bref pour gilles legendre pas de quoi
fracturé la majorité c'est même un
épiphénomène pour bruno keitel le fait
que la république en marche perdre sept
membres
c'est pas un sujet ce n'est pas un sujet
quand je vois combien la pandémie
mondiale qui frappe la planète a dévasté
des vies nombreuses y compris dans notre
pays près de trente mille décès ce n'est
pas un sujet quand je vois tous les
enjeux et les défis qui sont devant nous
pour cette fin de saison et surtout pour
la rentrée de septembre
les vrais problèmes ne sont pas dans le
nombre de groupes parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale si vous savez
compter vous savez que si on divise 577
par 15 on arrive à 38 ennemis donc on a
encore un peu de marge
alors merci à bruno keitel pour cette
leçon de maths bilan de la journée la
république en marche pour quelques
députés mais la majorité s'élargit avec
un troisième groupe pour quelles
conséquences politiques
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma
journée à l'assemblée merci beaucoup
thomas des prêts stéphane est restée
vous fait quoi sourire voire franchement
rire cédé 0 c'est très bien que la
majorité augmentent en nombre parce que
on va avoir du travail face à la crise
qui est tellement énorme si vous voulez
ça me paraît presque dérisoire ce qui
est important quand on sait qu on garde
une majorité solide pour pouvoir faire
un plan de relance dans les mois qui
viennent et perdrait quelque chose à
toutes ces manoeuvres voir petit grand
meneur s'il juge très importants
nettement les français s'en fiche à mon
avis en tout cas ce que je rencontre sur
le territoire s'en fiche merci merci
stephanie rice merci à vous tiriez
mahmoud est revenu sur lcp on va
terminer avec le jour d'après nouvel
épisode de notre collection d'entretien
ce soir le professeur jean tirole prix
nobel d'économie nous a accordé un
entretien sur la dette qui va payer la
facture du coc vide 19 corona bomb ou
impôts coronavirus plusieurs scénarios
sont sur la table regarder
c'est joli ce tableau quelqu'un qui
s'appelle l'autre vais-je me l'enlever
non non non pas du tout au contraire
c'est très bien bonjour jean tirole
bonjour et merci beaucoup de nous
accorder cet entretien alors nous allons
parler de la dette de ces montagnes de
dettes
lors des tenants de la france va
s'élever à 120 % du pib c'est du jamais
vu
9 % pour les déficits d'abord est ce que
c'est si grave
il ya des économistes qui vous disent au
fond circuler là rien à voir les taux
d'intérêt sont très bas
on peut emprunter ne nous gênons pas et
puis on remboursera plus tard sur des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années
alors finalement il est normal que les
déficits publics se creusent rebelles
pareil c'est tout à fait normal il faut
des mesures de soutien et donc pas de
problème un dossier le problème
effectivement c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer après alors les économistes qui
dit c'est pas grave vers son être
intéressantes sont très fermes ou un
point qui est jugé t dire que si les
taux d'intérêt sont moins rigaud à 0 ça
veut dire qu'on peut continuer à
s'endetter et finalement n'est jamais
repayer cette dette
tant que les taux d'intérêt restent à 0
mais ça il ya deux paris derrière ça y
est de paris d'abord c'est que les taux
d'intérêt vont pas remonter
donc si on parle je suis assez confiant
pour terre dans les quatre cinq
prochaines années et au maintien vont
pas remonter parce que il finit en
bagarre des taux d'intérêt bas des
banques centrales on le ferait un etc
mais ici on parle d'une dette à 50 ans
on peut pas parier que pendant 50 ans et
thomas pérenne
oh pas remonter l'autre chose qui
m'inquiète un peu plus c'est de la
spéculation entre les devises et on l'a
bien vu avec l'italie récemment
dès que l'europe fait semblant de ne pas
trop de soutenir à 100% jusqu'à 99 ans
en italie les les taux d'intérêt
commencent pour l'italie commencent à
remonter avec des sprays par rapport à
l'allemagne qui seront qui sont
importants les autres hedge précis ce
sont les écarts de taux d'intérêt et des
ratios taux d'intérêt auxquels l'italien
emprunter les taux d'intérêt auxquels
l'allemagne emprunte donc il peut y
avoir même dans cette période des
attaques des attaques sur les états sur
les dettes d'états des attaques
spéculatives absolument aller on vous
l'a vu avec la grèce à avancer les taux
d'intérêt qu'ils étaient extrêmement
faibles parfois même négatif et ça
n'empêche pas qu'il y avait des attaques
sur la grèce où aujourd'hui des débuts
de la taxe en italie et donc la gaffe
bien fait le mal qui est un peu vicieux
un cercle vicieux là parce que ça veut
dire que si on empruntait les taux
d'intérêt élevés ya plus à rembourser
évidemment au point de vue charge de la
dette
ça veut dire plus d'austérité en hiver
et ça veut dire que ça devient de plus
en plus difficile pour les populations
de soutenir cela d'où il ya un risque
effectivement que le pays fasse défaut
sur sa dette
cette option là monsieur pérol elle est
exclue pour la france on ne peut pas
faire défaut ce serait trop risqué
ces risques et ces récentes ont fait
défaut ça veut dire qu'il ya perte de
confiance dans le pays
scénario donc hautement improbable en ce
qui concerne la france ce qui se passe
c'est que dans ce cas de l'hostilité
arrive immédiatement puisqu'on doit
équilibrer son budget et imaginez
aujourd'hui qu'on doit avec il habitué à
ça serait ça serait catastrophique
donc c'est très très difficile
deuxième scénario qui semble très
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre
alors nous nous parlons la mutualisation
des dettes au niveau européen les fameux
corona bonze
expliquez-nous de quoi il s'agit et au
fond quelle est la probabilité qu'ils
puissent
au fond avoir lieu alors les corps en
avant c'est une mutualisation de la
dette c'est à dire que si l'italie fait
défaut sur cette dette c'est à
l'allemagne à la france notre pays de
payer
donc c'est une certaine forme de
solidarité et cette solidarité d'une
façon seule façon et il n'y a plus un
paradoxe c'est dire que aujourd'hui
l'italie n'est pas du tout responsable
des cures en avance et donc ça veut dire
que on devrait être totalement solide et
la réalité et c'est justement un moment
où on devrait être totalement solidaire
avec l'italie complice de ne pas l'être
parce que effectivement on a des
inquiétudes sur la solvabilité de
l'italie
l'italie fait défaut dans ce cas là
c'est à l'allemagne la france les autres
pays de payer et ça c'est un gars et un
coup donc le gars est effectivement
c'est que ça calme un petit peu la
spéculation contre l'italie
l'inconvénient c'est que ça va trop loin
ça peut engendrer une spéculation entre
la zone euro toute entière
dire que l'allemagne elle a très peu de
dettes environ 60%
donc elle peut payer mais elle peut
payer pour quoi pour elle même coup sûr
mais est ce qu'elles paient pour
l'italie et a fortiori pour l'espagne et
la france
ça paraît hautement improbable vous
comprenez vous d'un point de vue
économique
ce manque de solidarité en tant que
citoyen de l'europe du sud je
souhaiterais décor en avant c'est
évidemment parce que c'est dans notre
intérêt c'est moins dans l'intérêt de
leurs dehors et on a laissé jouer cette
fracture entre l'europe du nord et
l'europe du sud et maintenant on est en
train de payer les travaux de manière
après on peut à faire beaucoup par la
bce
c'est peut-être le scénario le plus
probable
l'action de la banque centrale
européenne la monétisation de la dette
expliquez-nous là encore on voit qu'en
ce moment la banque centrale européenne
dirigée par christine lagarde rachète de
la dette aux différents états de la zone
euro et allège de fait leur dette
comment est ce possible lorsque la bce
de racheter de la dette des états
soutient aussi les banques
donc on rachète vison de la dette
italienne donc ça permet à l'italie
finalement de d'émettre de la dette
puisque les gens qui achètent cède 2,5
après il peut être utilisé
rachetée par la banque centrale donc 100
110 42 ans à venir et donc ça permet de
l'italie de continuer à se refinancer en
rire pas de miracle cette dette reste
sur les bilans à c'est pas elle
disparaît pas tout d'un coup comme ça
pourquoi c'est la meilleure solution
selon vous l'avez cieux ne pas faire
faillite
donc elle peut toujours émettre des
liquidités par contre ce qu'il peut se
passer c'est que il ya de l'inflation
cirque elle l aimait beaucoup de
liquidités donc ça veut dire que les
agents économiques que ce soit les
banques ou les et et or ont plus
d'argent
et comme ils ont plus d'argent ils
peuvent dépenser plus
donc s'ils peuvent dépenser plus alors
qui est nôtre qui est qui est toujours
la même ça veut dire ça va se traduire
par l'inflation
ces mauvais l'inflation dans cette
période on n'a pas besoin justement d'un
petit peu d'inflation pour d'une
certaine façon rembourser ou en tout cas
alléger le poids des dettes
oui tout à fait sûr que l'inflation est
joe cole a d'abord si l inflation de 3 4
5 % je dirais c'est pas la fin du monde
et même tant mieux ça allègera un peu
les poids des dettes
si on retourne un système où l'inflation
et 10 15 20 % ou plus basse et c'est
vraiment dommage parce qu'on a on a mis
trente ans à vaincre cette inflation on
a réussi enfin à vaincre l'inflation et
donc avoir de nouveau une réflexion très
froid ça serait dommage
il ya un dernier scénario celui là est
peut-être le plus insoutenable dans la
période c'est au fond faire reposer le
fardeau sur les contribuables faire un
impôt coronavirus ou même faire
travailler je prends la france comme
exemple les français plus longtemps et
plus se serrer trop la ceinture ça
pourrait compromettre la relance
économique et donc il faut faire très
attention ne pas faire ça trop tôt ceci
dit on est immédiatement à l'esprit la
réforme des retraites cette année trente
ou quarante ans qu'on le dit rapport
chaque année qui 10 ans vaut alors
gilbert trêve n'est pas pérenne
donc il faut trouver une solution est-ce
qu'on refusera de d'améliorer les
finances publiques patrie une fine et
savard a reposé sur les finances que des
caches au moment où ses finances
publiques sont très détériorée non je
pense que c'est une décision politique
mais il faut bien réfléchir aux
conséquences de cette décision
continuer les réformes alors lesquels
précisément ballet réforme va les
réformes
elle s'impose s'impose clairement c est
qu il va falloir assurer la paix la
pérennité l'état providence qui n'est
pas assuré parce que là avec la dette
qui augmente avec des déficits publics
importants on risque de se retrouver
dans une situation où on sera obligé de
sacrifier une partie l'état providence
et et je ne le veux pas et je pense que
la très grande majorité des français ne
veulent pas donc il va falloir trouver
des économies alors ou qu'est-ce qu'on
fait précisément où trouve-t-on les
économies je pense qu'il faut réfléchir
à la notion d'austérité on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui que l'allemagne auster un
truc entre guillemets à quatre fois plus
de places dans les unités de soins sont
intensifs qu'elles dépensent beaucoup
plus pour soutenir l'activité que tout
autre pays européen
parce qu'évidemment elle fait des
économies diamant si on ne suit pas
l'allemagne dans les réformes
on risque de déclassement du français
enlevés sous les glaces on agirait de
façon plus générale il faut investir
notre sensation c'est la consommation et
on néglige l'avenir ces gens qu'on
néglige le climat on néglige à
l'éducation dans la france est
catastrophique dans les classements
internationaux
on néglige l'université en néglige un
peu dessous ce qui va préparer l'avenir
en france c'est une dernière question
dans cette période il ya les pessimistes
qui parient sur des convulsions sociales
liées à la crise économique qui va être
difficile et puis j'aime les optimistes
qui eux rêvent d'une forme de nouvel
humanisme cette solidarité sur des biens
publics comme la santé ou est-ce qu'on
vous arrange jean tirole or moi je suis
je suis répondrait qu'on arrive à
changer de société maintenant penser
qu'on va voir un grand soir et que tous
les coups les mentalités ont changé ça
me paraît un petit peu et alice
irréaliste même si je le souhaite
merci jean tirole de nous avoir fait
partager vos analyses sur cette crise
sans précédent merci au revoir
et voilà donc pour cet entretien avec
prix nobel français d'économie
ainsi s'achève cette émission se
retrouve demain pour un nouveau ça vous
regarde 19h30 rediffusion 23h30 et sur
la chaîne youtube
dell s'est fait tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire ces débats doc à
demain
[Musique]